ils se surnomment les balayeurs de
l'espace qu'ils travaillent dans
plusieurs endroits du monde pour astro
scale une compagnie japonaise fondée par
noboa okada en 2013 astro ce qu'elle a
construit un satellite el saad et dont
la tâche sera d'expérimenter la
récupération d'un objet en fin de vie
qui encombrent l'espace grâce à un
simple système d'aimants ce satellite a
été assemblé dans le laboratoire de
tokyo il est couplé à un autre satellite
plus petits qui servira de clients comme
on l'appelle en fait il sera l'objet
perdu à récupérer l satee a été
soigneusement emballés puis chargés dans
un camion
sous les yeux du patron et de tous les
employés sayonara direction le
kazakhstan la base de lancement russe de
baïkonour plus exactement
lancement impeccable d'une fusée soyouz
avec à son bord 38 satellite de 18 pays
dont deux pour une compagnie canadienne
de toronto kepler communication et le
satellite lcd de la japonaise astro
scale l'espace à certaines orbite est de
plus en plus encombré et selon cette
vice présidente dastros qu'elle une
ancienne de l'armée de l'air du canada
la quantité de déchets là haut est
considérable des très petits qui peuvent
aussi être les plus dangereux car on les
voit pas venir
il s'agit de deux satellites météo un
américain en fin de vie mais aussi un
chinois d'à peine deux ans el saad et a
déployé ses panneaux solaires les
contacts avec la base de contrôle de
londres sont bons quand tous les
instruments auront été vérifiées le
satellite commencera ses essais il va
d'abord lâché son client qui deviendra
un objet perdu à récupérer la première
récupération se fera de façon assez
direct les satellites récents seront
pour la plupart équipés d'une plaque de
couplage est monté en l'occurrence
la deuxième manoeuvre sera plus
compliqué une recherche de l'objet par
un parcours elliptique puis la capture
enfin une fois l'objet récupérer et
couple est de nouveau el saad et sortira
de son orbite et s'auto détruira avec
l'objet en entrant dans l'atmosphère
terrestre
le balayeur devient fossoyage une
prochaine mission consistera à retrouver
dans l'espace le dernier étage d'une
fusée de l' agence spatiale japonaise de
3 à 4 tonnes à l'inspecter et trouver
ensuite le moyen de la capturer d'autres
compagnies dont airbus songent à
utiliser un filet ou même dans certains
cas un harpon pour récupérer des objets
spatiaux balayeur de l'espace nous en
sommes fiers dit charité
[Musique]
nous entrons dans une nouvelle ère de
l'espace des dizaines de millier de
vaisseaux spatiaux seront lancés dans
les prochaines années
il coûte une fortune il faudra les
protéger un strauss qu'elle compte là
dessus et jean michel leprince sera du
canada à montréal